so personal question first because I've
heard cord talk a lot about how when he
read a eraser it felt like he was being
spoken to like the book was made for him
and I think that's one of the most
special qualities for a movie to have as
well and I think this movie is going to
do that for a lot of people out there so
what is an example of a movie that did
that for you where maybe it felt like a
character was talking directly to you
this one fair enough yeah yeah I mean
when I read the script I I felt um you
know I felt that uh as well in in in
fact cord you know adapted this script
from a novel called eraser by persal
Everett which is set in Washington DC
which is my hometown you know very you
know all the familiar hauns you know I
knew in reading the book but uh but but
C also reshaped a lot of uh the story in
his own image there are events that he
completely reworked for our film
um but the elements for me that really
uh in the book and in the script
resonated were the relationship to
family particularly to um to Mo to the
mother in that here's a man who's asked
to be the caretaker of she who was his
caretaker and and I reached that phase
in my life so that was very moving for
me and also the ways in which that
affected person personal life and and
creative and professional life in terms
of you know the sacrifices that are you
know that are required when you know
when the greater responsibility is uh is
at home um so you know I I knew this I
knew this guy intimately intimately that
might answer the first half of this
question but given that the story
evolved a little from book to screen
when you first accepted the role of Monk
what quality of his or part of his
experience were you most looking forward
to tapping into but then is there
something that emerged along the way
that wound up being more creatively
fulfilling to play than you ever could
have imagined I you know I liked the
tone I could get a sense of the tone
from the script quite clearly I liked
the you know I lik the irony and you
know the you know the the the kind of
biting wit in sarcasm there were
elements you know obviously with the
satire and the social commentary that
were full of those notes but um what I
found really again to be re super
fulfilling to play was the relationship
with the family that stuff because I'd
never been asked to play that before and
it was so rich and so much fun and it
just felt so right from the first moment
that uh you know we were all together in
the space there's a woman named Myra
lucrecia Taylor who plays Lorraine who
has been caretaker of the household
since we were children the first sound
out of her
mouth just brought me home and it and we
were off from there you know we we all
got on really well we all obviously
really love this material and we're
looking forward to playing it and to
playing it together and it just was so
organic and when I saw the film a couple
of days ago I saw it for the first time
in front of an audience in
Brooklyn and I just said to myself
wow that's a beautiful group of people
up there it really is and it but and
it's and it's and it's a group of people
this family this mad family that happens
to be black but it's just like anybody
else's family and I think audiences will
find themselves in that and surprising
ways and I that's pretty exciting
particularly now where you know there's
so much you know us them this that
division you know Madness in our country
um I think at least in this film we can
all sit down at the same table and agree
yeah we're all in it together I said
this to cour I brought it home to my
family for the holidays and everyone
loved it and when I can share my
favorites and it winds up being their
favorites too it doesn't have to be that
way but it always fills my heart when
that does happen that's awesome to build
on the incredible Ensemble you get to
work with here can you name a specific
scene when a scene partner did just what
you needed from them where it helped you
access something in monk that you might
not have been able to without them
oh uh I we our cast is so good I mean
across the board there's a young guy who
plays Ned who's in the Bookshop he he
was there for one day he was fantastic
as soon as I walked on set and saw him I
said that's Ned I
mean every character uh in this film and
every actor just came to play um
Sterling K Brown uh there's a scene you
know and he's the younger brother he's
the Menace he's kind of a foil to Monk
and ster was just having a ball with him
and he's fantastic in this film he's
he's you know he's wild unpredictable
able super funny but then he has these
moments which are
really um
tender and um and there was uh you know
we found just a kind
of just you know surprising fraternal
love uh that might be unexpected those
moments where the film is Rich it's
emotionally rich I know people have seen
the trailer and they you know they're
they're going to come for the laughs but
I think they're going to stay for uh for
for a richer meal even 100% I also think
people are going to stick around for
cord to see what he does next as a
director so given the fact that this is
his first feature what is something you
appreciated about his approach to
directing actors that you're excited for
more actors to get to experience in the
future well he's just got a cord's just
got a clarity about
him and he's got a he's got an ease and
he enjoys what he's doing uh you know I
think the humor that we see in this you
know in this film and that you know we
find in the script comes from him you
know he's got a he's got a nice tone to
him and that he brought that to set too
um uh but he's a he's a good leader you
know that's what a good director is good
communicator good leader get everybody
on the same page and uh and away we go
yeah I'm I'm so I'm so proud of what he
was done and I'm proud of the film that
we made together I wanted to sneak in
one Rustin question because I didn't get
the opportunity to talk to you about
that one
FM actually asked toeman recently too I
love many things about that movie but
one of the first ideas it puts forth is
the idea of owning your power which I
think is obviously so so important so I
wanted to turn that towards your career
do you remember the first time you felt
the power of your voice on set where you
were able to own your power and use it
to change a film or maybe this industry
for the better you know with this
film
um W um wrote a brilliant script it was
clear that he has you know uh an
understanding of story and the
architecture of story but he was a first
firsttime D
director um I wanted to make sure that I
was you know a good lead blocker for him
so that meant you know we get on set and
we you know we drive it we drive it you
know we you know make sure that we're
we're working efficiently we're working
hard and were working well you know to
to make you know his you know his first
experience that much more successful so
um you know perhaps this one you know
why not you know Love the One You're
With It was you know it was a fantastic
uh it was a fantastic experience and uh
I think for him yes it was a baptism of
fire but it was it was gentle um because
uh uh you know we all we all got a sense
too that we were doing something that
that could be pretty special and you
sense that on a set sometimes when the
crew works with a little bit more pride
in in in in in the details uh of you
know their their tasks and when the you
know the silence on set gets a little
deeper you know we sense that you know
we all kind of pushed uh pushed this
thing along uh understanding that it was
cords first time and uh he uh you know
yeah he he uh
you know he came out I think he came out
doing all
right